guten morgen herr murphy ist deutsch
mehrheit da mit seiner schulklasse der
lehrer kontrolliert die hausaufgaben so
leute und eure hausaufgaben
viktor hat seine hausaufgaben vergessen
wie kann das denn sein dass du deine
hausaufgaben vergessen wird er erfindet
eine ausrede weil mike und das buch
geführt hat agatha hat auch ihre
hausaufgaben vergessen weil meine katze
auf siegkurs hat der lehrer kann es
nicht fassen ich kann es nicht fassen
calvino hast du denn deine hausaufgaben
nein ich habe keine zeit meine oma hatte
gestern geburtstag
die klasse schreibt einen test es ist
ein vokabeltest der lehrer steht auf und
kontrolliert die schüler
julia hat sich einen kette gemacht wie
versteckt den spickzettel unter einem
taschentuch der lehrer kontrolliert die
tische julia was ist das denn ein
taschentuch julia das liegt ihr aber
glauben ja der lehrer hat julia nochmal
davon kommen lassen
niki hat auch einen spickzettel gemacht
der spickzettel ist auf seinem arm
was hast du da ja ok micky was ich das
bin ja ich verstehe sie hübsch gefällt
mir gut schreibt weiter bitte überzeugt
bei lucas ab ich hab das ist ganz genau
gesehen zukunft die ganze zeit bei
herrschaft zur strafe mit da drüben
alleine bitte schneller ab mit ihr
hubert wurde erwischt zur strafe muss er
jetzt alleine am tisch sitzen
konrad komm bitte an die tafel
der lehrer bittet konrad nach vorne
bekommen was ich dann mache ich will
dich ab fragen warum es zeigt mir bollig
deutsche
nein mit sicherheit nicht das ist afrika
von rand hat keine ahnung wo deutschland
liegt eine wieder hin
konrad ärgert sich dass er nicht gelernt
hat
das war unsere neue episode super easy
firmen aus dem johannes paul den zweiten
gymnasium in anspruch der popolski in
polen
[Musik]